I've actually had to take a second job
cleaning to help pay the wages of my
staff at my preschool
just some of the casualties of a broken
child care system by the time all three
of them go to school we would have spent
over a hundred thousand pounds on child
care with the cost rising and
availability dropping we've got three
staff that have left and gone to work at
Sainsbury's don't tune on quick with
crackers exclusive figures show the UK's
missing out on billions of pounds of
economic output every year good job that
lost potentials from women like Cherry
it's Madness isn't it because I could be
working more hours and and
being more productive paying more tax
instead forced to take an extra six
months unpaid leave from work after
maternity someone who works for the NHS
in an understaffed role but it's a
flawed system and I think the government
must know that it's not working and this
is feels like willful negligence that
they're just not doing anything about it
it feels really unfair that we're forced
as a family to make these really
difficult decisions
figures given exclusively to Sky News
show the economic potential of women who
want to work extra hours but can't
because of child care cost and
availability those foregone hours alone
are estimated to be worth up to 38
billion pounds annually the equivalent
of one percent GDP in other words one
percent of UK economic growth per year
I get more money cleaning toilets than I
do working and owning a business
Kate's worked an extra 60 hours as a
cleaner last month on top of running a
preschool to cover costs
I actually think maybe the people who
actually organize the amounts of money
should come and visit us to actually see
what it is we do and why that money just
isn't enough because I don't think when
they sit in their little offices they
actually know it's not the real world
though is it we'd have to close
eventually if if there's no funding
go
her split life is an example of why more
and more and defunded child care
settings are closing this doesn't just
matter for the hundreds of thousands of
women who want to work more but can't
afford to it also matters to us all
because with so many women and it is
predominantly women Limited in their
working potential so too is economic
growth and the tax revenues that could
and would be generated for this country
at a time when the UK is grappling with
a crisis of economic inactivity in its
Workforce we struggle to grow our
economy by one percent per annum having
Child Care sorted and adding to the
economy that way is a substantial and
sizable gain government can borrow to
invest in hard physical infrastructure
so Railways and roads but we think
there's a strong economic case for
treating child care in the same way
sitters and it's so depressing the
government has spent over 20 billion
pounds to help families with child care
but low wages mean even attracting staff
in is a struggle look George look at can
you see people exiting the sector and
getting a job at Sainsbury's on more per
hour because the accountability and the
responsibility that's put on us is
massive those things rightly should be
in place and we're very happy to carry
out those things but we just need to
have a fair amount coming in from the
funding to be able to fund amazing staff
the numbers just don't Stack Up and
campaigners argue the system's
exacerbating gender inequality we're
seeing at the moment a big Exodus of
women from the labor market that's going
to impact the gender pay Gap we have a
skill shortage in the UK and yet we know
we have hundreds of thousands of women
who are now stay-at-home mums who
desperately want to work but they can't
afford to do so underfunded Child Care
holding back the economy a compelling
argument to drive change as costs for
many spiral beyond their means Adele
Robinson Sky News